hi guys I'm Ren Jenny I am a producer at
box and I'm Melissa I'm an associate
producer at box we both work on this new
series called missing chapter where we
end up doing a lot of field producing
which means that a lot of our biggest
interviews are done far away from home
so with that we wanted to give you our
five biggest top tips for field
producing all right tip number one is
the internet so I use Google Alerts a
ton for reporting I create Google Alerts
for story topics that I'm working on and
even like broader phrases so missing
chapter is about hidden histories so I
have a Google Alert set for hidden
histories or little known history so
that a lot of random things on the
internet get pinged to my email when
interesting stories may happen and for
this project since everything is video
it's so important for us to be able to
have really great archival and visual
images that we can use and so some of
what we've been doing is just starting
with maybe something that seems like a
really powerful image and the powers of
the internet mean that we can find it
somewhere and the vast crevices of a
search engine do over first image search
alright tip number two tip number two is
pretty interviewing which is that we
generally reach out to everyone that we
would like to have in the piece and talk
to them on the phone ahead of time so we
can really know what they're gonna say
and be ready for that but also to get a
ton of information that leads us into
new avenues and our reporting number
three is timelines and fact sheets so
especially for stuff like missing
chapter where the reporting spans so
many decades we make these fact sheets
and timelines so that when we're out in
the field we know what yours are
important what to ask our interviewee is
about and what locations are important
number four is call sheets which are so
important when you're out in the field
not only do they let you know when
you're gonna be somewhere and where you
have to be but because we're working
with crews that are on the ground
it really helps everyone to be able to
coordinate and know exactly where to be
and when sometimes you don't have the
best cell service or you know you're
holding equipment so just to have that
piece of paper in your hand going analog
is the best way to be able to know what
you're gonna be doing next yeah and also
weirdly the most helpful thing or one of
the most helpful things on this call
sheet is writing down the sunrise and
sunset times because those are those
hours are the best times to be filming
and it's just helpful to have a quick
thing to look at to know when sunrise
and sunsets gonna happen tip number five
is this app I use where you can annotate
your interviews as they're happening so
say you're sitting in an interview and
you don't have time to actually
transcribe what they're saying as you're
interviewing them because you want to be
paying attention to what they're saying
maybe you're paying attention to
shooting it as well there's a lot going
on so that makes it really easy to just
sink in the time code with the camera
and you can do these little shortcuts
like great or good or bad or funny and
it makes scripting on the back end a lot
easier to just be able to go in and see
what times people said great things cool
so that has been five tips that helped
us get by and field producing and if you
want to see the fruits of our labor
check out the upcoming episodes of
missing chapter on the main youtube
channel for voxcom
thanks for watching thank you